I have a bunch of shapes here let's
think about what they are so this first
shape here
you probably recognize it it's the shape
of the moon in the sky at least on a
full moon and we call it a circle now
what makes it a circle well when you get
further in math we come up with fancier
ways to define a circle but one way to
think about it is if we take the center
of the circle and if we go across we go
from one side of the circle to the other
side of circle through the center that's
always going to be the same length so
that's the same length as this as this
as long as we go to the center of the
circle as that now if that's a circle
what would something like this be what
you might call this an oval and all all
circles are ovals
but this oval is not a circle because if
you have its center say right over there
this distance going in that direction is
going to be much shorter or just shorter
than this distance right over here so
this one right over here is not a circle
this one is now what about this shape
over here that has three sides one two
three you could also say it has three
corners one two three well if you have
three sides we call that a triangle tri
angle whenever you see this tri right
over here that's a good sign that you're
dealing with the number three this is a
triangle has three sides now what about
these shapes over here these shapes are
interesting how many shapes so how many
sides do these shapes have well if you
count them you see that this one up here
in purple has one two three four sides
this one has one two three four sides
this one has one two three four sides
this has one two three four sides so
they all have four sides so our name for
any shape that has four sides is
quadrilateral kua drei quadrilateral
quadrilateral and when you see this
at the beginning of the word that's a
pretty good sign that you're dealing
with the number four four sides four
sides
that's what quadrilateral means but
these are all different special cases of
quadrilaterals and actually you could
even have a quadrilateral that looks
like this you could even have a
quadrille that looks like this one two
three four sides as long as it has four
sides it's a quadrilateral let's think
about each of these so this shape right
over here what you might see is the
corners the corners all come in
sometimes this is called square or
sometimes you could call it a right
angle so and notice I could put a little
small squares here so if all four
corners are square or they are all come
in at a right angle like this then
you're dealing with a rectangle you are
dealing with a rectangle and so just to
be clear this down here is not a
rectangle notice this corner right over
here if I try to put a little square
here it would either look like this so
it doesn't it doesn't the two sides
aren't on two sides of the square or it
would look like or it would look like
this so this is not a square corner and
neither there is this or neither is this
so this is not a rectangle all four
corners need to be square this one also
is not a rectangle notice the corners
are not the corners are not right angles
so this isn't directed rectangle this
isn't directing what about this well I
can do that I can put little squares
I could put a little squares in the
corner or I could see that they are all
right all the corners are right angles
so this actually is a rectangle as well
so these are both these are both
rectangles
now you might recognize this purple one
on the left is a special type of
rectangle not only are all of the
corners square not all do they have
these right angles but all the sides are
the same length or at least it looks
like it from this picture this side is
the same length as this side the same
length as that side same like this that
side so if all the sides are the same
length in all the corners are
are square or they have right angles
well then we call it a square so this
right over here is a this right over
here is a square special type of
rectangle this one not all the sides are
the same this one all the sides are the
same now what if we go down here it
looks like all the sides are the same 1
2 3 4 but it doesn't necessarily R it
wouldn't fit perfectly if I try to put a
little air here doesn't fit perfectly
these aren't right angles so if all four
sides are the same and that's all we
know about it we call it a rhombus we
call it a rhombus so you might be saying
wait wait the square all four sides the
same is that a rhombus yes it is
so the square is a rectangle it's a
rectangle and and it is a rhombus so
this last shape here this last
quadrilateral what's interesting about
it is you have two of its sides going in
the same direction so this one right
over here notice what I mean by the same
direction and sometimes this is called
parallel if I draw two lines here these
two lines are never going to cross each
other so these two lines are parallel if
you have opposite one pair of opposite
sides that are parallel we call them
trapezoids
we call them trapezoids notice the other
lines the other opposite sides these
will cross these will cross eventually
so that right over there is called a
trapezoid